[Music]  hey I'm miles an [ __ ] when I was a  kid I wanted to be a hero but instead I  grew up to be a nobody  excuse-excuse is impeached random  weirdos and made them fight to the death  and the internet love it.next wins look  this is gonna sound really [ __ ] weird  but you helped me with my hands yeah  you're right that does sound pretty  [ __ ] weird  you have 24 hours to kill next sale you  die  it's shooting  [Music]  don't shoot me I don't want anything to  do with us these guys came to my house  last night they're making me fight but I  have a plan  come on you can stop trying to kill me  and give them you in  No  here's what we'll do and running  mistakes were made 10 million viewers  you have made history I never wanted any  of them it's not over till I say it's  over I wouldn't do that if I was you  you'll just end up blowing your damn  face off then you'll still be depressed  even more depressed probably cuz your  fucked-up face  [Music]